October, 1988.
SCP Foundation Agents Cyril Novak and Diana
Fischer had been dispatched to Austria’s
capital city, Vienna, to investigate a series
of mysterious, unexplained disappearances.
The Foundation was unsure if these events
were connected, or even anomalous in nature,
but they had reason to believe that something
was lurking beneath the dark streets of Vienna.
A Foundation operative embedded in law enforcement
informed the organization that the authorities
were panicking, with an emphasis on withholding
information about these disappearances from
the public and the media.
Novak and Fischer conducted a survey of the
city, observing the streets at night and keeping
a watchful eye on those who they deemed at-risk.
It was the undesirables of society that were
disappearing in droves.
Unsupervised children, vagrants, the homeless.
All those that were indisposed, vulnerable,
and otherwise at risk of being forgotten by
society were potential victims.
According to several sources, these disappearances
were taking place near access points to the
city’s subterranean infrastructure.
Sewer holes, access tunnels, storm drains.
Anywhere that led to the underground was a
potential risk-site.
After a few days of standard exploration and
information gathering around Vienna, Novak
and Fishcer moved on to interviews with law
enforcement and public officials.
Using a variety of cover stories, they managed
to pry out a deadly secret from the mouth
of the police chief.
Human remains had been recovered near the
disappearance sites.
The authorities opted to keep them a secret
from the public, so as to not cause any panic
of a crazed serial killer on the loose, or
inspire fears of something even worse lurking
the city’s underground.
The Agents seized the three cadavers, and
alerted the Foundation that their mission
had been progressing as expected.
The bodies were transported to Humanoid Containment
Site-282 in Graz, Austria, where they were
immediately examined by Dr. Felix Gärtner,
who performed an autopsy on the three corpses.
If the Foundation was unsure about anomalous
involvement before, they were certain of it
now.
The bodies were in shambles, mutilated beyond
belief and altered into an almost unrecognizable
state.
The mere stench of them caused personnel working
with them to rush to the bathroom, and even
those that could typically keep their lunch
down had a difficult time examining them.
Cadaver-A was in pieces, and the cause of
death was determined to be from exsanguination,
or the extreme loss of blood.
Cadaver-B was missing some important fleshy
components inside and out, some of which had
been removed entirely.
The cause of death was presumed to be traumatic
cardiac arrest.
The third corpse, Cadaver-C, was barely a
body.
Instead, it was a collection of bones and
fluids.
The cause of death, because of the opaque
conditions the cadaver was found in, was unknown.
These grizzly deaths were only the start of
the Foundation’s containment of this anomaly,
and are far from the worst this file has to
offer.
This is SCP Explained, and today we’re going
to be looking at SCP-3288, a collection of
entities otherwise known as The Aristocrats.
Dr. Gartner’s analysis of the cadavers came
to a single conclusion: a human could not
do this.
In fact, he compared the deceased’s injuries
and conditions with the bodies of victims
of hyena attacks.
All sustained injuries weren’t the result
of a blunt object, sharpened blade, or a firearm,
but instead resulted from a combination of
teeth, claws, and raw physical strength.
The bodies had abnormally large bite marks,
approximately six times the size of adult
human teeth, yet closer analysis revealed
that the indentations did, in fact, coincide
with human teeth.
Whatever did this possessed more than sixty
teeth, unevenly distributed over six distinct
rows, and required jaws much larger than those
of ordinary humans.
There were unique patterns among these markings,
suggesting that it wasn’t a single entity
that ravaged these corpses, but multiple.
There was no doubt about it, these deaths
were anomalous in nature.
The Foundation issued a designation for the
entities responsible, SCP-3288, and deployed
Mobile Task Force Sigma-6 (“Hellsingers”),
a special unit trained to capture deadly anomalies
in the field, to bring SCP-3288 into Foundation
custody.
The operatives were tasked with patrolling
the Leopoldstadt District, the area where
the most disappearances had occurred.
Secrecy, as usual, was a top priority, and
members of the Task Force took extra care
to conduct their operations away from the
public eye.
As the purpose of this mission was to contain
the entities for further study, the operatives
were also ordered to refrain from lethal force,
and to target SCP-3288 with tracking darts
to prevent them from escaping.
The Task Force divided up their assignments.
Twelve operatives would patrol the district
and search for any suspicious activity, while
ten others would remain watch in positions
with unrestricted views of sewer holes and
other underground access areas.
For the first few hours, things were quiet.
But then, two operatives stationed near the
Danube Canal made a report to the rest of
the team.
Someone near the Canal was screaming, not
loudly, but in a muffled, faint way.
The operatives took initiative and ran off
to investigate the matter themselves, requesting
backup at the same time.
Reinforcements arrived less than three minutes
later, but their teammates could not be found.
Moments later, their bodies were discovered
by another operative, mangled beyond belief.
Both operatives were killed, and alongside
them was the half-consumed corpse of a local
civilian as well.
One operative’s body was recovered from
the canal, while the other was found after
following a trail of blood and fluids into
an alleyway.
But despite the loss of life, the mission
was still deemed a success.
Before being mauled by the SCP-3288 instance,
the Task Force operative managed to shoot
the entity with a tracking bullet, a piece
of technology utilizing satellite location,
which allowed the rest of the team to follow
the entity into the sewers.
The tracking was working perfectly, and the
entity was shown to be fleeing into Vienna’s
sewer system, until the signal faded somewhere
near the Hofburg, a palace constructed centuries
ago that was once host to the Hapsburg Dynasty,
and presently serves as the seat of power
for the President of Austria.
The team was confused, as the fading nature
of the signal suggested that the tracking
bullet had been brought into a location far
deeper than the Viennese sewers were believed
to accommodate.
The mission moved onward, into the depths
of the sewers in pursuit of SCP-3288.
The following day, the Task Force had assembled
a strategy for mapping and exploring the Viennese
sewer system.
Constructed in the mid 19th century, these
sewers were part of a larger network of subterranean
tunnels that included catacombs, abandoned
wine cellars, and underground rivers.
Without proper planning and clear communication,
death could be a very real possibility, and
not even one caused by SCP-3288.
The task force was divided into four teams
of five.
Three to investigate the sewers and one to
remain on standby.
By triangulating the location of the tracked
instance, the Foundation was able to pinpoint
the general area they would need to explore.
By blocking off certain exits and surface
access points, they hoped to minimize the
possibility of the entity’s escape or exposure
to the public.
While the primary objective remained containing
an SCP-3288 instance for scientific research,
lethal force was authorized to be used in
case of emergencies.
The Foundation valued the lives of its trained
soldiers, and put them above nearly anything.
Still, the authorization of lethal force spelled
impending doom for many experienced veterans
of the task force.
They knew all too well about what kind of
entity they were up against when the Foundation
opted to skip the containment step and prioritize
getting out alive.
A team of operatives reached their destination
safely but didn’t discover anything of significance
during their trek through the sewers of Vienna,
at least not at first.
After several hours of investigation, they
encountered human skeletal remains while making
their way through waist deep sewage.
One member of the task force pointed out a
loose brick in the wall, and then another
did the same minutes later.
Inspection of the area found a number of loose-fitting
bricks that were able to be removed with ease,
as if they were put there to hide something.
When the entryway was fully unearthed, it
revealed a previously unseen chamber, whose
walls were engraved with the House of Habsburg’s
coat of arms.
Operatives inside the chamber immediately
knew what they were looking at.
A family crypt of royal bloodline, never uncovered
before.
The forgotten atmosphere made them feel like
they were discovering a secret they were never
supposed to know.
24 sarcophagi were found within the chamber,
and historical records of the sewers and surrounding
area mentioned nothing about a crypt beneath
the palace.
Multiple statues were recovered from the chamber
as well, depicting veiled women with hushed
expressions, holding a finger to their lips.
Almost as if to say that this place was a
royal secret, and trespassing had grave consequences
- get it?
“Grave” Consequences…No?
Ooookay…moving on - The tombs themselves
were intricate, decorated with ornate jewelry
and various expensive embellishments, but
did not include placards, markings, or any
indication as to who was entombed within.
When the operatives opened the sarcophagi,
they were disgusted.
The skeletal remains of over 300 bodies, all
displaying severe and likely fatal birth deformities.
The team was at a loss.
What was the meaning of this room?
The entrance had been destroyed some time
ago, with stairs shattered and buried among
the stone.
Near the other side of the row of tombs was
a vault door, coated in bronze and bearing
the coat of arms of the Habsburgs.
A seal, written in latin, was engraved beneath
the coat.
Translated, it read: “For Purity of Blood”.
The task force tried to pry the door open,
but it wouldn’t budge.
Opening it would require special equipment,
and after what they had witnessed inside the
sarcophagus, some members of the team were
even hesitant to continue trying.
The team was ordered by the supervising team
to hold their location and await the arrival
of another team that would open the door.
Foundation agents on the surface organized
a temporary evacuation of the Hofburg building.
The team waited for backup throughout the
night.
They made attempts to open the vault, but
to no avail.
Once the surface had been properly evacuated
and an infiltration team arrived inside the
chamber to assist with the vault door, the
gate was able to be opened using oxygen-fuel
cutting torches over a period of two hours.
Once opened, the team was met with an ominous,
descending staircase, leading to an unknown,
dark location underneath the palace.
An eight-man squad, heavily armed and equipped
with recording devices, ventured down the
staircase.
Radio transmissions from the squad grew increasingly
faint over time.
When they reached the estimated 65 meter mark
underground, their communications arrays were
barely audible.
At the bottom of the stairwell was an ornate
foyer.
Instead of decaying, gray stone walls and
oceans of sewage, there were marble floors,
with felted carpets and white painted walls
and ceilings.
This chamber was found to be architecturally
identical to a certain wing of the Hofburg
Palace.
Furthermore, the chamber was clearly built
in the 18th century, as many aesthetic choices
popular during that era were clearly present.
Much like the crypt, there were sculptures
and statues, but this time there were also
columns, paintings, and tattered tapestries.
Some of the operatives admiring the beauty
of the room overlooked that on every piece
of art, any and all depictions of the human
form were defaced and altered.
The air was rancid, with operatives describing
the odor as similar to rotten meat and stale
sweat.
The floor and walls were discolored with what
appeared to be dried, old blood.
Regardless, they moved forward.
In between the space’s equivalent of the
Hofburg Imperial Library was a laboratory,
not found in the palace above.
An operative collected numerous documents
related to alchemy, biology, and the occult,
as well as a journal of transactions, contracts,
and private writings.
These documents were delivered to the above
personnel, and were later translated by Foundation
personnel.
All along this chamber were human remains,
decomposing and strewn around the palace.
Suddenly, a bell tolled, and the music of
a pipe organ began playing discordantly for
over three minutes.
Operatives hid themselves and deactivated
their flashlights, some hiding behind the
curtains of a large opera hall and others
behind large instruments.
They heard footsteps in the distance.
Minutes later, a group of figures emerged
into the palace hall.
The entities the Foundation had classified
as SCP-3288 were now fully visible.
Their outfits were typical of the 18th century,
containing deep shades of red that contrasted
with their stark white skin, porcelain masquerade
masks, and powdered wigs.
Their bodies were monstrous, with arms dragging
across the floor, uneven faces, long fingers,
some possessing more than 10 of, and hunched
backs.
A pair of smaller instances entered behind
the hoard of the others, and one blew a rusted
trumpet while the other held a banner depicting
the Hapsburg’s crest.
The trumpeter began speaking, but its words
were unintelligible, and raw, guttural moans.
They ran out of the way, their stunted legs
causing them to trip across the floor.
There were now over several hundred SCP-3288
instances inside the ballroom.
Multiple operatives activated silent distress
calls, requesting backup to deal with the
mass of entities they would have to contain.
The instances bowed their heads, and another
mass of footsteps were heard as a group of
SCP-3288 instances carried a morbidly obese
instance atop a throne.
It wore a cape, a red veil in place of a mask,
and a crown too small for its head.
It was evident that this was their leader.
A large cauldron was presented before the
king.
A small instance climbed atop the king’s
shoulder and lifted the entity’s veil to
speak to it.
The cauldron was uncovered, and the king lurched
forward, grabbing the tub and pouring its
contents down its massive mouth.
Some of the king’s disgusting meal spilled
from its mouth, revealing a small human child
with severe deformities.
The SCP-3288 instances roared in applause
and began to feast, all while the cacophony
of noise brought on by the various instruments
inside the ballroom raged on.
An operative hiding behind a harpsichord was
discovered by an SCP-3288 instance, and quickly
consumed by it in the feeding frenzy the entities
were engaged in.
Still barely alive before being entirely digested
by the entity, the consumed task force operative
triggered an explosive device from within
the entity’s stomach.
With a look of immediate uncomfort, the entity
suddenly exploded, taking out several other
nearby 3288 instances with the blast.
The entities were distraught, and while they
were distracted, the task force lept into
action and rendered the remaining SCP-3288
instances not killed by the explosion unconscious
using devices loaded with a gas.
As Foundation reinforcements arrived, the
surviving SCP-3288 entities were contained
and moved to Site-282, including the massive
king, whose body was transported using a specialized
crane.
After the removal of all remaining entities,
the palace was filled with cement and reburied,
with the Foundation making sure that no one
would ever discover it again.
After the King was contained, Foundation personnel
were shocked to discover that the entity could
speak.
In an interview with the hulking monstrosity,
it revealed that its name was Maximillian
the Great, a patriarch of the House Habsburg.
The entity’s eyesight was severely damaged
from centuries of living underground, and
the Foundation was able to get the King to
comply by shining powerful lights in its eyes.
The entity was delusional, believing itself
still to be inside the palace, and referring
to the doctor as nothing more than mere meat,
which it wanted to consume.
When the doctor was able to convince the King
that he too was noble blood, which the king
believed due to his unstable mental state,
the entity uttered a chilling statement:
“We are of the same noble blood.
But some are more noble than others.
Our bloodline is pure - untainted by outsiders.
We do not eat human.
We eat peasants.
We eat undesirables.
We devour life undeserving of life.
That is the nature of nobility.
What else would be the point?”
DNA testing revealed that the king was, in
fact, descended from the House of Habsburgs,
as all SCP-3288 instances were.
But what of the journal entries discovered
inside the palace?
After translation, the Foundation found that
they contained the writings of Leopold I,
a Holy Roman Emperor and member of the Habsburg
house in the early 1700s.
His writings detailed his desire to claim
power over the royal family, as well as his
fears of an increased number of inbred, deformed
members of the Habsburg House.
Leopold details meeting a woman of unknown
origin, who promised him that his family name
could live forever.
She taught him arcane knowledge involving
experimentations of the flesh.
Small animals, and eventually humans were
subject to Leopold’s disgusting, unholy
experiments.
Even his mystical teacher became disgusted
with what her tutelage had wrought.
As payment, she demanded that Leopold cease
his reign, deliver his land and wealth to
common people, and destroy his various deeds
and titles.
Leopold refused, and had the woman burned
at the stake for witchcraft.
Eventually, Leopold’s experiments to make
his bloodline perpetual resulted in the creation
of SCP-3288.
Years of inclusive family ties mutated over
one another, generation after generation,
until a horde of SCP-3288, living underneath
the palace and feasting on a diet of human
meat, were created.
For years, the surface Habsburgs catered to
SCP-3288’s depraved and disgusting needs,
providing them with a slew of humans to feast
on and a lavish lifestyle akin to the one
lived by the nobility above.
One other document revealed to the Foundation
that there were multiple hives of SCP-3288
existing throughout Europe.
Most were discovered and neutralized, but
the original writing was heavily damaged by
mold, meaning that there were some locations
the Foundation was unable to uncover.
Colonies of SCP-3288 instances buried underground,
snatching humans without any care.
Mutating their own deformities and living
horribly, unable to be stopped.
A captured SCP-3288 instance in Germany revealed
that there was another entity, similar to
the King in authority, by the name of the
Empress.
It had this to say to the Foundation, upon
being contained:
“The meek will beget the strong.
The doomed will beget the chosen.
Don't you see?
The greedy will devour the charitable and
the merciless will ravage the peaceful.
We will make the world as perfect as us.
We will all be aristocrats in the end.
And our Dynasty will never die.”
Now go watch “SCP-1678 - UnLondon” and
“SCP-5545 - Mysterious Tunnels in Antarctica
- ABNORMALITY” for more anomalous subterranean
locations!